mais je trouve cet accessoire est
franchement hyper cool et puisque je
vous le recommande
je vous l'offre eric addo ne me
remerciez pas merci aussi logitech qui
jouent le jeu et qui vous l'offre
[Musique]
il ya un peu plus d'un an je faisais une
une série de vidéos d'été dans lequel
vous donner des conseils pour votre
stratégie youtube menace bien évidemment
à toutes les personnes qui veulent faire
des vidéos qui font déjà des vidéos sur
youtube ont fourni pas mal d'astuces
comment optimiser vos vidéos comment le
faire comment améliorer votre contenu
fils comment améliorer votre stratégie
youtube comment gagner début comment les
transformer en abonnés csa bon c'est pas
le thème principal de machhad m jme dit
extrêmement déçu je trouvais intéressant
et aujourd'hui j'ai envie de faire un
petit extra qui lie cette question de
stratégie youtube est également la
question de technologie pour vous parler
de matériel et il est très important
effectivement lorsque vous voulez que
des personnes regardent aux vidéos et
envie de les voir d'avoir des vidéos de
qualité prend des vidéos de qualité il
faut du matériel de qualité enfin voila
je un peu un peu standard et notamment
et se développe de plus en plus le live
streaming que ce soit sur youtube que ce
soit sur twitch fatalement mais
également sur facebook
et pour ça il vous faut forcément du
matos de qualité souvent c'est compliqué
d'aller streamé avec son boîtier parce
que son boîtier son appareil photo comme
agen gh5 il vaut mieux partir sur de la
webcam n'est pas de la webcam chip pas
de la mauvaise qualité sinon ça ne
marchera pas vous n'aurez pas de bons
résultats au paf et ça fonctionnera pas
terriblement donc du coup on m'a proposé
de tester une webcam de logitech est sur
le coup je sais que ça pouvait être
vraiment intéressant pour vous montrer
du matériel qui vous permet d'optimiser
votre qualité pour wolf training et
cette webcam
c'est celle là c'est la logithèque brio
quatre cas je la trouve vraiment
intéressante
ça fait quelques temps que l'attestent
le trouve super je fais pas de live
streaming dont vous n'allez pas voir en
live streaming avec par contre je vais
me filmer avec vous allez voir le
l'outil est franchement hyper cool vous
avez du vrai bon matos ici vous avez
derrière une solution logicielle qui est
vraiment intéressante
on peut faire plein de choses déjà je
vais commencer par vous montrer un peu
d'un côté hardware matériel
comment et cette caméra qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire avec on peut la mettre sur
peter pas mal de choses et ensuite je
montrerai d'un côté logiciel comment ça
fonctionne et vous allez voir que ce
petit truc là franchement ça envoie du
bois
vous savez quand on la prend dans la
main tout de suite ça paraît petit mais
pas si petit que ça et c'est franchement
une terrasse du sud parce que cette fois
deux cas vous pouvez la mettre comme
vous voulez vous pouvez
la poser à plat vous pouvez venir la
couche et vous pouvez la poser sur un
ordi je vous montrer comment ça marche
vous pouvez venir enlever cette partie
là et l'insérer directement grâce au
pass vip vous la mettez sur un pied vous
en faites ce que vous voulez vous n'êtes
pas obligé de la positionner sur un
ordinateur
si vous voulez la punition un ordinateur
vous pouvez faire mais vous avez pas mal
d'options ça c'est cool elle est
orientable et je trouve que de ce point
de vue là il ya un vrai beau boulot qui
a été fait de la part de logitech en
plus nous ont rajouté ce petit truc
alors je vous laisse 30 secondes 10
secondes pour deviner ce que c'est allé
en commentaire vous marquez qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc à quoi ça sert
1 2 3 4 5 ap on enchaîne en fait ça
c'est bien pour la vie privée pour tous
ceux qui craignent de se faire pirater
leur ordinateur vous positionnez ça vous
baissez et vous n'êtes plus filmés alors
par contre là dedans vous avez deux
micro omnidirectionnel le son sera
toujours capter mais en tout cas lorsque
vous le posez quelques parcs elle est
branchée que voulait pas voir de risque
pas prendre de risques vous l'a
positionné comme ça ça franchement c'est
hyper cool alors en termes de
branchement c'est de l'usb tisser le
câble est juste énormissime ses 2,02
vous branchez derrière en usb type c est
ensuite en usd 3 alors usb 3 usb 2 si
vous voulez avoir la 4k ça sera
forcément usb3 sinon full hd de l'usb 2
fonctionnera le câble est franchement
très épais comme ça vous pouvez la
déporter sur un pied pour filmer c'est
franchement bien cela je vous prends un
macbook pro je veux montrer la fixation
vous allez voir c'est franchement cool
vous prenez votre webcam vous l'a
positionné comme ça vous avez un petit
patelin la de sécurité dessous tout doux
donc ça va pas du tout a dit mais
l'avant de votre ordinateur vous le
positionner comme vous voulez ça
s'intègre parfaitement bien à votre
ordinateur vous pouvez complètement
venir à la positionner à plat par
exemple vous pouvez a posé sur un meuble
sur ce que vous voulez
dans ce sens là et ensuite vous allez
régler l'inclinaison plus au plus bas
grâce à cette petite webcam vous allez
pouvoir dire filmé en 4096 par 2160
c'est la 4k uhd ça marche franchement
bien à 30 images par seconde
et si vous n'avez pas besoin de capter
avec voulais filmer en full hd pouvait
le faire en allant jusqu'à 60 images par
seconde
même en 720p si vous voulez c'est fluide
ça marche bien et si vous filmer en full
hd vous avez un zoom numérique x 5
bien évidemment vous avez de la mise au
point automatique et en plus vous avez
un champ de vision qui est complètement
paramétrable et ça c'est la partie
software
vous avez donc un petit logiciel dédié
qui va s'appeler caméra settings qui est
franchement cool tu voulais pouvoir
faire pas mal de choses avec donc image
standard image grand écran bon ça c'est
sympa ça change pas grand chose
anti sentiment hdr vous pouvez activer
désactiver comme vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez surtout régler votre champ de
vision un champ de vision à 78 degrés
schirrhein peu standard 65 degrés on va
vraiment venir resserré sur le sujet 90°
c'est davantage grand-angle je pense
notamment lorsque vous avez plein de
monde que vous faites par exemple de la
vidéoconférence entre amis ou ce que
vous voulez ça c'est franchement cool
mais vous pouvez aller beaucoup plus
loin dans les paramètres avancés
vous pouvez régler comme luminosité en
fonction de la pièce dans laquelle vous
êtes régler votre contraste voilà voyez
c'est quand même sens vraiment du goût
en fermant comme vous voulez la mise au
point automatique alors là elle est
automatique ni après pouvait venir
vraiment la paramétrer sur ce que vous
voulez l'intensité des couleurs et une
balance des blancs automatique que vous
pouvez venir up passé comme vous voulez
bon après il faisait un peu fantaisiste
mais vous voyez dans l'absolu cette
webcam vous permet de faire pas mal de
choses avec le hdr est une technologie
qui s'appelle wright light bright lights
à la française sont les frenchies
vraiment rightlight fruits avec like 3
vous allez avoir des images qui vont
être complètement optimisé et qu'ils
vont vraiment venir ce calibre et en
fonction de tous les sens que vous allez
avoir imaginé je me filme comme ça j'ai
derrière un faux très lumineux et bien
il est complètement possible d'avoir ma
tête net d'avoir le fond malgré tout
assez clair et notamment en situation de
contre jour donc ça c'est intéressant
laissez moi vous le montrer ce que ça
donne lorsque j'aime être une lumière
derrière à contre-jour vous allez voir
résultat est franchement cool
voilà mon éclairage à led voyez il est
derrière viennent quand même franchement
plutôt fort et malgré ça on voit bien la
tronche ça va alors bien évidemment
c'est pas magique
imaginez derrière vous allez pas
forcément voir le soleil de dos mais
voyez quand même j'entendais mon visage
dans l'absolu ce que je vous
conseillerais moi c'est vous prenez
votre éclairage vous le mettez de
l'autre côté vous le mettez en face vous
vous éclairer de face et voyez là c'est
pareil je suis pas cramé sens bien je
suis plus éclairés là que là mais ça me
qu'on pense vraiment je suis pas cramé
d'un côté son visage je suis pas
complètement sombre de l'autre il ya un
vrai beau boulot qui est fait là dessus
d'un point de vue logiciel et je trouve
que viennent pour ça en terme de qualité
quelles que soient les conditions de
luminosité cette caméra logitech va
vraiment devenir complètement optimiser
votre rendu vidéo je vous le disais vous
avez deux micro omnidirectionnel
personnellement lorsque vous voulez
faire du live stream que je vais
vraiment vous conseillez là dessus c'est
de prendre un micro externe parce que
sinon la qualité de site va pas être
extraordinaire je vous conseille
vraiment d'investir dans un petit micro
peut vous trouver des tout petits micros
plein la bouche pas besoin de lire
beaucoup cool soit vous avez des petits
micros qui coûtent pas forcer notre cher
et que vous permettront d'avoir un son
vraiment de qualité sur du live stream
donc ça c'est cool et pour le stream
justement parlons-en
il fonctionne avec explique avec obs et
avec plein de logiciels pour stream et
mac pc à partir de windows 7
et même si vous voulez utiliser les
usages professionnels notamment sur la
conférence skype c'est complètement
possible sur mac par exemple il est
reconnu par quintiles a reconnu
directement par mail ical donc vous
allez vraiment pas vous embêter s'est
pas non plus magique ça va pas venir
remplacer votre réflexe lorsque vous
voulez faire vos vidéos courante je
dirais sur youtube facebook twitter que
vous voulez mais pour vraiment la
question de la streak sous ça vraiment
bien en plus le produit est garanti 3
ans ils ont fait un beau packaging
il n'y a pas à dire franchement la boîte
est sympa et en plus de ça à l'intérieur
ils nous ont mis un joli petit étui pour
venir promener votre webcam si jamais
vous êtes en mode nomade et que vous
voulez faire lifestream je ne sais où
vous la prenez vous l'allaitez dedans
c'est beau c'est pratique c'est rapide
ça se mange bien rien pour ça bravo vous
vous en douterez cette caméra de
logitech n'est pas gratuite non plus par
contre elle coûte un peu moins de 250
euros et vu le service rendu surtout vu
le prix des boîtiers croyez moi je
trouve que c'est un excellent rapport
qualité prix
je vous dis selon moi ce qui est
vraiment très important lorsque vous
partez sur un accessoire comme celui-là
c'est d'aller rajouter 2
duo de qualité un petit micro et xenia
branché dans votre ordi parce que ça
tout simplement
c'est très bien pour la vidéo pour
l'audio c'est pas forcément ce qui va
être le mieux mais je trouve cet
accessoire est franchement hyper cool
et puisque je vous le recommande je vous
l'offre et les cadeaux ne me remerciez
pas merci aussi logitech qui jouent le
jeu et qui vous l'offre vous pouvez donc
la gagne et vous avez le lien en bas
dans la description
dépêchez-vous parce que l'opération va
durer pendant quelques jours donc si
vous visionnez la vidéo
quelques jours après sa sortie le
concours ne sera plus actif voilà donc
les premiers arrivés seront les premiers
servis
y en a une à gagner donc dépêchez vous
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce que vous faites des live sur youtube
twitter ou facebook
est ce que une webcam comme ça ça
pourrait vous tentez est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est un bon accessoire est
ce que vous l'avez déjà essayé celle là
moi je la trouve franchement très bien
je trouve qu'elle a un excellent rapport
qualité prix
si elle vous botte je vous mets un lien
aussi la description si toutefois vous
voulez acheter que vous l'avez pas
gagnée au concours allez savoir
parce que façon il faudra une seule a
gagné donc dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bac et je voulais aussi un
lien pour aller voir mes vidéos de
conseils pour votre stratégie youtube
qui reste malgré tout d'actualité
je vous embrasse vous donne rendez vous
très très très rapidement pour parler de
teck de plein de choses donc je vous
embrasse et à très bientôt ciao